um so that i don't cut into high pink's
time so um
so we've got off to a really good start
with chipra stock and in some sense
shipwrest talk gives you a good sense of
what we want to cover as part of this
program so in in some sense
what we thought when we came up with
this program is that we want to think
about bayesian and minimax approaches to
sequential decision making problems
and
many of you may
sort of think like many of us work on
this and we think that this is a really
sort of hot and ongoing area although
the the title that i just said or the
the small description i gave bayesian
and minimax approaches to sequential
decision problems uh if you search for
it you'll realize that this was actually
a title of a paper written all the way
back in 1949 by ken arrow david
blackwell and abraham gershig so you
in even though the problems feel really
new they've been around for a long time
and many different communities have been
thinking about it and we have many of
you here today and in during the
semester to sort of discuss with each
other as to how we think about these
problems
so
i'm sid banerjee i'm one of the
co-organizers of this program uh
we have the three other co-organizers so
ship agarwal who you saw earlier today
is one of the other co-organizers as
well as todaris liquidus and shuchi
chawla
and in addition to us co-organizers we
have four workshops at the boot camp and
then three other workshops each of which
have a a team of people helping organize
this uh especially for the boot camp
this is being organized by me um nika
lab at the back and adam german who is
online somewhere and who will be here
from tomorrow
uh so
we would love feedback on this we would
sort of please feel free to catch up
with us and tell us about how
about what we're doing and what else we
could do to help out and now in addition
to all the organizers we also have an
amazing team of research fellows so we
have seven research fellows who will
hopefully introduce themselves over the
next few days as being as part of being
the
session chairs
and
as part of their duties what they're
doing in addition to the talks is
they'll be preparing some kind of like a
site document a blog post of some sort
to
go into more details into each of these
talks so keep an eye out for that uh and
if you're interested in following up on
on these topics we should have some
material available so that you can sort
of read that up before you come for the
next few workshops okay so that's
that's all i wanted to say about the
program uh
so the next
stock is going to be given by hyping and
hyping is going to switch tax instead of
thinking about the stochastic version of
the multi-unbanded he's going to look at
the adversarial version
and briefly so hypeng is uh assistant
faculty uh
assistant professor at usc uh and before
this he was at princeton and also
microsoft research and he is
one of the foremost experts in this area
and one way to see that is many people
consider there are three main
conferences for learning so icml new
rips and colt
uh
hyping i believe has won a best paper in
all three
which i think we i propose we henceforth
declare the high-paying slam
so
over to haiti
thank you thank you
thanks for having me um so yes i will be
talking about the serial version of
motion bandits and which is um i guess
arguably less known compared with the
gas dependence but i i promise it's
going to be interesting and helpful okay
useful
so and uh so so given uh shipper stock
this morning i don't think i need to
motivate this problem anymore um so
let's just directly go into the the
formal formulation
which is uh first a study by our sisa
bianchi front and superior two decades
ago
okay so here's the formulation
uh again so you you learn for t rounds
and as the learner each time you pick a
one of the k arms okay so stripper was
using
the number of arms this morning so i
will switch to k
and so id is the one is the under you
use select
time t
okay
so now the the important change is that
this is an adversary that simultaneously
decides a loss vector lt okay so that so
lt is a vector k dimensional vector so
that each coordinate lti denotes the
loss for
mi okay and i assume that they are
normalized so there is every losses
between zero and one
so again i'm switching uh from rewards
in the morning to to loss okay which is
um for some reason it's the convention
for uh this topic and i would
come back to this later
and but obviously you can translate
between rewards and losses
okay
and
the important thing is here is that the
adversary can decide the loss vector in
some arbitrary wave it doesn't have to
be drawn from some distribution okay it
can depends on the algorithm it depends
on the learner's previous
behavior and also can even depends on
the distribution uh
of for this round of it okay it cannot
depend on id because otherwise it's just
too difficult too difficult for the
learner okay otherwise it can depend on
all the things in the
past okay so that's the key difference
compared to stochastic uh maybe
and finally as always the learner
suffers and observes only the the loss
of the arm that is
selected okay
so that's the the formulation and and as
the goal of the learner is still
to minimize regret which is very similar
to
the stochastic case so the request is
comparing the difference between your
total loss and the loss of the best
fixed arm
okay so i start i will use i start to
denote the the overall best arm in
hindsight
and you you want to compete with this
best term
so if you're regressive sublinear again
it means that on average you are doing
almost as well as
the best arm
the stochastic maybe that we discussed
this morning is obviously a special case
of this formulation where these loss
vectors are generated in some iid way
so korea
right
so so now let's let's take a closer look
so if i it's the first why why do we
care about cellulosis so when do we have
adversary environments
well i mean so maybe we don't always
have an adversarial environment but i
think the key point is that here we want
to remove any distributional assumptions
okay there's no assumption at all on the
on the loss vectors which uh hopefully
leads to more robust algorithm
okay
and and also in the second reason says
for some cases for example if we are
playing games using this kind of uh
multi-ambient algorithm then then indeed
you are against a potentially
adversarial opponent
in which case this kind of adversarial
setting is very helpful
and second question is why do we care
about regret okay in particular why do
we care about this this formula so there
are two two very natural questions the
first is why do we compare with the
fixed arm i star while the losses are
changing right so in the stochastic case
it makes sense there's one fixed term
the defects dump okay at the best dump
okay but in the adversarial setting the
losses are changing so why do we still
care about the best term so maybe
there's no single arm that's good
overall
so why do we still uh care about this
well the the end so this is a very
concern and there are many fixes so all
these different
notion of requests or stronger notion of
regret they propose to kind of address
this kind of issue okay so that's a rare
concern
but there are there are other fixes that
we are not going to talk about in this
talk
and the second question is why do we
still compare with the same lte sequence
while the behavior has changed so we're
asking ourselves in retrospect what
happens if i keep picking um i stock
what i what i would have suffered okay
but in this case if you are you go
against an adaptive
maybe algae has also changed
right so that's also a very concern
but so so first of all notice that this
notion at least makes sense for
something called a previous adversary so
foreign independent of your your past
selected arms
okay so so the fsa can still look at
your algorithm and still can decide in
some arbitrary way but just not depend
uh depending on your past actions okay
so in this case then ld is fixed no
matter what i pick then then this regret
makes total sense okay
but even if you're against an adaptive
adversary so another series that can
depend on your past action
uh uh there are again there are fixes
one one notion is called policy regret
that's exactly to uh to kind of address
this concern
okay
and but i want to emphasize that even
despite all these issues studying the
standard regret in the adversarial
setting is still very meaningful okay
for two reasons first
it's just a foundation of all the all
these other stronger regret measures
okay in the sense that you either extend
the techniques for uh minimizing
static i mean the standard regret to to
uh this this stronger notion or in some
cases you can even reduce this problem
to minimizing the standard regret
okay so that's why standard regret is
fundamental despite all
these issues and that's why we care
about this
and and also for games when you you in
fact you are playing against an adapter
adversary is still some somehow this
standard regret is still very meaningful
right for example subliminal regret
actually implies conversions to things
like equilibrium or optimal social
welfare
yes even though it it seems like this
doesn't make sense in the adaptive case
but still it has strong implications
so that's why uh we care about regret
and that's why in the rest of the talk
we will focus on how to minimize this
i hope this convinces you
feel free to interrupt if you have any
questions
right
so so to me i i see this problem or
other extension as a marriage between
two researchers one is the online
learning with adversarial losses
resolution and the other is just a
band feedback or more generally any
partial information feedback that
okay and and
again to me it even has uh that deeper
root in the in the first literature it's
online learning with every several
losses
and i say that because uh
as far as i know all algorithms for
these kind of problems are based on the
following recipe okay so first you come
up with an algorithm that works with
full information feedback okay so in
emotion bandit full information just
means that alt the entire loss vector is
revealed at the end of round t
okay so you you not only see the uh the
loss of the selected arm but also loss
for all the other arms
okay so that's kind of like the the
the typical problem in the first kind of
resolution so you first do that and then
in the bandit setting what you need to
do is just to come up with the last
estimator
okay you don't have the entire the full
information of lt but you just based on
what you have to construct lost
estimator and then you just feed it to
the full information algorithm
okay so that's that's usually the recipe
for for this kind of adversarial band
problems
and the key challenge is really you need
to do these two uh in a way so that the
variance of the estimator is well
controlled
okay so that's that's the most important
thing that we will keep discussing today
okay
and because of this for this talk i will
start with the free information case
as a womba
okay we discuss how to design an hour
some even for the for the case with full
information
then we will go to the band case and i
will highlight how to control the
variance of the estimators and i will
also highlight the differences between
these two settings like with full
information or with banded feedback
okay
but now let's directly go to the full
information case which is also known as
the expert problem
so again it's just the free info
counterpart of fs0 mab and it's our
first proposal from the fury
so it's exactly the same setting you
pick an arm
the adversary can decide the loss vector
arbitrary you suffer the loss of the
selected um except the only change is
that you again you observe the entire
loss vector instead of just one
coordinate
okay
same goal you want to minimize regret
exact same goal
but if you think about it this is not
trivial even with full information right
because the again the losses are
changing over time
so how how should i uh how should i know
which item to select
all the yes of the time t what does that
first thing yes and yeah good question
what was the knowledge that just
happened yes uh
uh knows the algorithm but not the
randomness and also everything before
time
all right so
so you you probably have seen this
problem and it's kind of always which is
something like this and just directly
show the algorithm um
so
so it's easy to see that you you have to
randomize because i'm not going to go
into it but it is
necessary
and you you're going to sample i t from
a distribution pt
such that
pti is proportional to this thing okay
so the weight to put to pick mi is
proportional to e to the minus eight for
some learning rate positive learning
rate times the cumulative loss of mi up
to time t
so it's very reasonable like if the log
if the cumulative past past community
loss is large you're going to pick this
mi with smaller probability
okay
and and this is uh
again one of the most classical
algorithms called by many names it's
discovered but in many different areas
independently uh here i will just call
it hedge okay
and then
okay this is also not the only algorithm
is that there are many other ios but
this is the the most uh basic one
right so that's the always um so now let
me just give you a very simple analysis
just one page
um so we're gonna do this potential
based analysis
so i'm going to define the potential vt
in this way okay it looks complicated
but notice that this sum this summation
is nothing but the normalization factor
in the definition of pt plus one
if pt plus one is proportional something
like this when you normalize this is
exactly the numeration factor
okay so that's the potential
so as always if we study the kind of the
increase of the potential between two
consecutive rounds okay and so this is
by definition it's just this
nothing special
so now let me split the numerator into
two terms okay the thing that depends on
the path before time t and the thing for
time t
okay again equality
so now if you look at this orange part
it's exactly pt pti
okay so a again by definition the
algorithm said that pdi should be
proportional to this
and and by proportional i just mean it's
exactly this right this is the
domination factor
okay so in other words the the increase
of potential is just simply this
okay
so now that the rest is just uh
kind of some calculation your first
thing to do is to approximate this
exponential by a quadratic okay you just
use something like this which is true
whenever z is positive
okay and it translates to a condition
that lti has to be a positive
and and again i assume lts between zero
and one in this case so we can just
approximate this exponential by this
quadratic
let's simplify it a little bit so sum
over i of pti is one
the second term becomes this inner
product
and the final term is this this
quadratic
okay
so last inequality just by bounding a
log of one plus z by z which is always
true so then you get this
okay so if the either cancel here and
eight squared cancel with one later you
could run it
okay i hope that's clear
so now obviously just a sum over t and
telescope and rearranging then you get
something like this the loss of the the
this is this is exactly the expected
loss of the the algorithm right you pick
id according to pt
so dot lt is exactly your expected loss
responded by the
the increase of the or the decrease of
the position
plus this projected term
okay
so the final step is just to realize
that by definition this final potential
is actually related to the loss of the
best arm okay so by the definition is
something like this so realize so notice
that there's a sum of k positive terms
here let's just lower bounded by the
terms that related to i star
okay i'm bounding this uh k terms by
just one of them
and then like an exponential cancel
eight one over eight and eighty cancels
you just get this which is again the
loss of the best arm
okay
so
so again it means that this term is
basically the loss of the best arm you
move it to the left you get exactly the
regret right this is just a regret so
i'm using this as the the basic vector
with the i stars is coordinate being one
okay the expected regret bounded by the
initial potential plus this projected
project
right and by definition initial
potential when so when this is nothing
here you just get k right so you can
lock k of eta plus this thing
okay so so let's recap at this point uh
so i have proved this expected regret
bound and the the only condition i've
used here is that uh lti is positive or
non-negative
okay it can be as large as uh as you
want but this bound host
okay and this is going to be important
for the bandit case okay just keep it
keep in mind
okay
but for the full information case when
okay so when these lti they're all bound
by one so obviously this term this
summation over i is just uh
bounded by one the sum over t you get
either t
so you have log k over eta plus eta t
and when you pick the optimizator you
get root t log k
so that's how you prove a
regret bound for the h wisdom and this
turns out to be information
theoretically optimal so you cannot do
any better than this
yes
so if you you have a condition that
losses between zero and months
and you have negative loss they're easy
picks
yes you need to shift them to positive
losses
okay okay so
um
for food information case it doesn't
matter you can just do negative process
but the important thing is the battery
case which which is using the
fact that l is to use the exponential
inequality yes
but in fact so if
if the anti-issue is larger than minus
one
then something like this also
like maybe a large constant
but it cannot be too negative and that's
the case
okay
so so before we move on let me just
give you a kind of a more modern view of
these kind of algorithms so so
so at this point it's kind of well known
that hatch is actually a special case of
a more general framework uh called on
follow the regularized lead ftrl okay so
this kind of generally always it looks
like this so again your distribution at
time t
is is the you're trying to minimize the
sum of these two terms okay the first
term is just uh in terms of the the
previous uh cumulative loss
okay that's that's very intuitive you
want to find a p to minimize the the
velocity you have observed so far
but you also want to uh uh regularize
this okay so so psi here is a
regularizer of p
okay and let's say again either is some
learning rate
so that the algorithm is
more stable than than just following the
the current best access
and again has just
it's a special case in the sense that
when you pick uh the psi of b as the
negative shannon entropy which is this
then you can verify that this is exactly
the same thing as the hedge algorithm
that i showed you earlier
okay
and so we will be seeing more other kind
of
regular regularizers in this stuff and
the and we will be uh also using this
this regret bounce okay so this is a
a bounce that holds for general
regularizer okay it holds under some
conditions that will
uh will be satisfied for this stock and
i'm not going to go into
uh the the details but but let's look at
the bound okay so again it's saying that
for any any distribution you want to
compute two right you regret again p
star
is bounded by the sum of these two terms
okay so the first term is usually called
the kind of the regularization panel
determine which i will always use a rule
to denote
so if you you see this is sine of p star
again p starts your combat uh
capacitor minus the minimum value of
sine
okay so usually you have no information
about p star and you just bound this by
the maximal value of sine so that the
penalty is actually exactly just the
range of the
regularizer
okay
that's the panel determined
and it's the base term which i will use
right to denote throughout talk is
something like this so here this
notation it means this kind of a
quadratic norm this kind of local norm i
call it okay so it's ld transpose times
the the inversion of your regularizer
evaluated at pt
and then lt
it's just a
quadratic norm with respect to matrix
and the matrix is the
hessian inverse at pt
right so it's caused but uh stability
term because it's indeed a bound on like
how close pg and pt plus one are
how stable your algorithm is
if if this term is small it means the
algorithm is stable
it's more stable
i'm trying can you explain again why the
second term represents stability
okay so
i actually i didn't prove it but uh
intuitively it you see the difference
between pt and pt plus one is just lt
here that's the only difference in uh
when you look at the definition of pt
and pz plus one so when ld intuitively
if lt is large
you're less stable
like a time invariant regularizer or
this one's too well
yes yes a good question so uh this is
the most basic problem where you use
the same regularizing every time
but indeed you can do something like
time varying regularization
all right and
so again i'm not gonna prove this down
but we're gonna try this about multiple
times in this stock and let's give
again verify
back to the sheldon entrepreneur where
this also is just
so you see that so this the range of
ancient general measures is of course
just log k
if that's the log k over eight and that
that we had before
and then this this stability term so
okay let's first look at the hessian
so the the the entropy the the
derivative is is just
one plus sloppy
the the second derivative is one over p
take the inverse you get you get p
okay that's how you get the p and this
is of course a diagonal matrix so that's
where you get this
okay and this is exactly the same bound
that i i got in the last slide
how should i think about the
trade-off
is the coefficient next to the stability
sort of making this with a stronger uh
function over there how does the
behavior of the algorithm change yeah
the very good question basically like
i mean
if you make this larger then this is
smaller right it's larger that always a
small state and
and we are actually going to see
different trade-offs
but i mean overall you see that this is
independent of t but this is going as t
so the kind of the right straight up is
always accelerated will be something
like one two
all right
so that's enough for the warm up and so
now let us go into the band case from
the
mission depending
so the obvious issue in mab when you try
to apply this also is of course that you
don't see the entire last vector
and as i said the standard solution is
just to construct a loss estimate based
on the information that you have okay
and uh standard one is just the kind of
the inverse importance weighted estimate
that that i assume you you have seen in
many different contexts okay so
so let's define this last symmetry l hat
lt hat in this way so the ice coordinate
just uh the loss of mi divided by the
probability of selecting mi times
whether you in d select
this um
okay require id is the actual arm that
you
you select for time t
okay
so first of all notice that this is a
non-zero only for one coordinate so for
the i that's the selected um for all the
other arms is just simply zero
okay
so that's why it's actually computable
using just uh the information you have
you only see one coordinate and only for
that coordinate you will have the loss
divided by the probability and all the
other coordinates you just set it to be
zero
that's why it's computable
and second a second clear fact is that
it's unbiased so in the sense that when
you take expectation with respect to
this id
you get exactly uh the loss of mi
okay and this is easy to see because the
expectation of this indicator is simply
just the probability of picking this arm
and and obviously it cancels with the
denominator
so you get in expectation l hat is just
l
so that's why this estimate makes sense
and as i said once you have an estimator
all you need to do is just to feed this
estimator to the full inferior algorithm
as if this is a full info problem
okay and that that's if you do this uh
you feed this to hatch you get the you
get the classical always an xp3 okay it
stands for exponential weight for
exploration and exploitation
and again this is the the the
[Music]
update rule of the algorithm and instead
of using l here you use l hat
okay
so now let's uh pause and think think
about
this ourselves a little bit so where
exactly is the exploration okay so we
know on this morning that for these
problems we have to uh exploit and
explore
okay so in ucb you have this uh
exploration bonus term to help you
explore
and but for this also where exactly is
the exploration
okay
so the answer is that the explosion is
implicit in the sense that just look at
what happens
every time after you pick a numb okay
after you pick an arm
uh the the loss for every other arms is
zero by the by definition
but for this arm it's not it's uh i mean
it's at least zero okay and most of them
is just positive okay and based on the
update rule of course next time the
probability of picking the same arm will
be smaller
again whenever you pick this arm next
time you will pick this up with a
smaller probability
and that's expiration right
i picked it this time next time i will
explore other arms
that's why the uh it has exploration and
it's kind of implicit
and this also can finally go back to
this question there's indeed some a
symmetric between losses and rewards
okay so when you're dealing with rewards
you cannot just simply like do not like
just negate and and and do negative
losses okay that's not going to work for
the same reason like if this if if
there's no negative side here this is
positive it means that every time you
pick this arm the next time you will
pick it with even higher probability
so then there's no expiration
so obviously just i was it was not going
to work
okay
yes
it's not so obvious
so if you saw a low reward no
it is because again every other arms get
zero
and you get something
you can have some positive
so next time you you have to have a lot
larger
a larger probability
so that's why you cannot directly just
do negative losses for rewards and and
so of course you can still do it with a
reward just shift it to positive
it
and then press one so there is a
responsive
and then you can use the
cells right i hope that's clear
and so now let's look at the regret of
this across four hours so as i hinted
before the key challenges is read the
the variance of this estimate okay so if
you look at again this estimator and
okay by variance i i always mean just
mean second moment okay expectation of
the square
okay so again the expectation is with
respect to i t
so by definition it's just this
so squaring the indicator of course
gives you the same thing and expectation
of the indicator is pti
that's why in the end you get one pti in
the
denominator
okay and this can be huge right if if
you pick i with a very small probability
then you have a large variance which
makes sense because with very small
probability you will get information
about this arm
okay and there's really no way to avoid
this you cannot come up with an
estimator so that every arm has a
constant uh variance this is impossible
by only looking at one uh entry of this
nonsense
okay and recorded that loss vector is
changing over time so
that's all the information you have the
information from the path it doesn't
help
okay
and again there's no way to avoid this
but what you can control is how the
variance affects the regret so what what
you're going to pay so how okay how is
your regret uh going to depend on the
variance okay and now let's so let's
come back to this this boundary we
proved earlier okay so i emphasized
earlier that this bond only depends on
the fact that lti they are positive
okay and no matter how large uh these
losses are this bounce still holds okay
and that's indeed the case here in in
the bandit case when when i'm doing this
uh estimator so there's positive but
they can be very large if pti is small
but this month still holds
so again you have a penalty term here
and stability stability term here
so now let's see why it's important
to have this this kind of thing so you
see that when you take expectation on
both sides on the left you basically get
the expected regret
and on the on so at the left you get
expected regret and on the right you
have this and you see that so again this
expectation of the ls square is just
this variance or second moment
okay and it's actually controlled by
this actual pti so you just don't simply
you don't simply just pay for the
variance
but instead you pay like
a pti fraction of it
okay
and
just plug in this this calculation you
see that there's some magical variance
cancellation happening here so this pdi
cancels with this pti
okay
that's why even you have you can have
large variance it doesn't matter so in
the end this term of course sum of i it
becomes k sum of t you get t k
so now your stability becomes eta t k
and of course when you pick the
optimizator you get root tk
block k
so this is really dependent on the fact
that like that's the hessian
you just pay an extra square root k for
the
for canceling the p
yes that's exactly right yes
so again if we've mentioned this term
it's just one mouse now it becomes k
so this what one can we hear
so when i say the left-hand side in
expectation is the expected regret i
actually cheated a little bit because
um this only holds when the other three
is obvious so when i start the best arm
doesn't depend on on the
the learner's behavior then when i take
expectation i indeed get regret but if i
start actually depends on everything in
the adaptive adversary case then i
cannot like take expectation easily and
i have to do something else okay so you
i'm not i'm not going to discuss that
but um basically you have to first prove
a high probability bound and then you
take
then you get the expected bound okay and
that requires changing the alison a
little bit
but eventually you can still get
something like this
right
there's no further question
um so let's look at the lower bound okay
we have upper bound now and the lower
back is of course low tk that you
already saw from super stock this
morning
uh so super low buys for a stochastic
case and a lower bound for stochastic is
of course also lower bound for the
adversarial case because every server is
only harder
okay
and but but let me just uh give you a
kind of informal proof a very quick
informal proof it's not difficult at all
the first imagine environment where
every
uh every loss is just simply but only
one house okay every arm is the same
across all the rounds
so now
give me any algorithm let me run this
algorithm in this naive environment and
then there must be an arm that is not
selected more than t over k times let's
say an expectation
okay
that's the always access structure norm
so now what the adversary can do is just
to kind of secretly change the loss of
mj to something slightly better
to disarm that the always
not selected often enough let's let's
make it the best uh
just by a little bit by effect of
a gap of root
k over t
okay
now in this new environment let's run
the same algorithm again
uh the the claims that the author uh
wouldn't realize the change information
theoretically right because you're
you're trying to distinguish these two
bernoulli
and
right information theory tells you that
you need at least one over gap square
and that's this is a gap so you need
kind of like
say again
so you need this many times to to
distinguish you stupid
but as i said this tree is not fit
enough right and so
so if only you can prove that the semi
always zone will not predict
often enough for example
it less than half of the times
okay and then basically you you have the
bump every time you you're not selecting
mj the best arm you incur the gap amount
of regret
and you you're not picking it for half
of times that's why you suffer with tk
regret
and that's it
you can make every step formal
but this is kind of the idea
okay
so now obviously the the natural
question is that there's a gap between
the lower bound and the xb3 upper bound
a gap of root log k
so so which one is tight
it turns out that uh the lower bar is
tight so meaning that you can improve
the
the the algorithm
and here's the the algorithm okay so
we're gonna use ftl again so in fact in
this entire talk we will just be using
ftr but just with a different
regularizer okay so recorded this is
just
the common form of ftr and you just need
to decide the regularizer
for xcp3 we are doing strength and
entropy and now let's do a different
regularized let's do cellulose entropy
with a exponent of one half
so serious entropy is a family of the
two of uh uh
entropies and and uh basically basically
depending on the uh exponent of pi you
get different uh uh uh form of service
entropy and now let's just do one half
so you get root pi
so this this always is taken uh this
simplified form is taken from
epinephrine lee and tawari but it's
really based on an earlier more
complicated are we sent by or deeper in
putback
exactly
when
you have a societal entropy in the limit
when when this exponent is
one then you get
a shannon engine
okay
so let's do this and then let's now
analyze the request so record i show you
the this general bound and we are now
just going to apply it okay so obviously
you need to just figure out these two
terms the panel determines the
stabilization
the panel determined like i said is
roughly just the range of the
regularizer and in this case the range
is just root k it's very easy to see the
the maximum is achieved by
a distribution that put all the weight
on one arm and the minimum is true by
uniform
and that's good where you get root k
and now let's look at the more
interesting uh part of stabilization
okay again definition is this
and
uh let's look at the hatching is of
course again a diagonal matrix because
it's decomposable
the root so the derivative is one over
root and then uh the second derivative
is one where p to the three halves and
you take the inverse you get this
so notice that for strength and entropy
you have an exponent of one here
and now you get 1.5
which is smaller so you have a smaller
stability term
and and it's and now the next step is of
course just take the expectation so that
this is the variance and as we did
before variance is roughly one over pti
so it's cancel with exponent you get
root pdi lti square
and of course by by bounding this by one
and then crosses one you get this
expanded by root k
okay
another important thing is to notice is
that now i'm achieving a different
trade-off between the penalty and
stability for strength entropy i'm
getting low k for penalty and k for
stability
and for cell essentially i'm getting
root k for both
and of course in in here my regret is
actually the product of them
okay and and this is uh cellulose
entropy it's exactly lock k factor that
in the stream and then should be
and that's exactly the last step uh you
request this by picking the optimizator
you get root t k
and it matches the the lower bound
exactly
without any local rhythmic factors
okay
so so you don't have to do one half you
can do something like one third or two
thirds it doesn't matter if you do one
third you get maybe a k to the two
thirds here and k to the one third as a
stability just a different kind of
trade-off but in the end the product is
the same
yes
the general
function psi is different i believe from
the
basic group we saw and does it also
require l hat to be non-negative yes
it does
all right
so that's just it's great that we have
the minimax request for this problem
already so you so you might wonder like
so okay we remove the locker why does
another it's just a small term
so first of all for me um given the
fundamental
how fundamental this problem is i think
it's important but like it turns out
that more importantly this
this result turns out to be very
fruitful or this always
and this is kind of a teaser for satori
stock uh
right here in an hour so it turns out
that this
algorithm
is not only minimax optimal in the
adversarial case which we just proved
but surprisingly also instance optimal
for the stochastic case
so in a stochastic if you run the autumn
you turn the running rate right you will
get the one of the delta the one will
get bound that stripper was talking this
morning
the instant optimal bound you can get it
with the same algorithm
so there you have it one hour isn't that
optimal for both cases
and again that's surprising because this
kind of ftr framework
is originally proposed only to do with
adversarial case but turns out that
somehow it kind of automatically adapt
to the stochastic as well
again
we'll talk more about this
yes that's the only one at least
no no that's the beauty you just set it
to be one half yes
okay
so okay i'm not going to talk about how
to adapt this the cast case
will talk about it but in the rest of
the discovery we'll talk about a
different kind of adapter
bounds that uh
depend on the the the specific problem
instance in a different way okay
so then the motivation is just that the
worst scale robustness this kind of root
tk is nice but it might be overly
pessimistic
your environment might not be
really adversarial okay so the question
is can we kind of adapt to easy
instances uh with a smaller regret
whenever you are facing with
easier instances
okay
so over the years we uh we have
many results around this line and there
are many different ways to measure
easiness okay so the the first one uh is
kind of the last of the best um okay so
let me call it l star which is again the
cumulative loss of i star
okay so the hope is that whenever this
is small
uh you should suffer smaller regret
so if you have an arm that's actually
good
then uh hopefully the problem is easier
to learn
okay
and this this turns out to be india the
case you can actually get this kind of
regret bound uh replacing t with l star
because up to some uh a lot of factors
that i'm hiding in this other notation
okay
again l star in the worst case t
so in the worst case you are still
getting good tk but the hope is again
maybe your best arm is much better than
the worst case which is linear
and in which case your request is also
much better than root tk
so there's one way to do it there are
some several approaches and i will
discuss the second one by first step or
later
okay and instead of looking at just the
cumulative losses you can also look at
other quantities such as the variance
okay so this is just average variance of
all the arms so l i is i'm using i to
denote the cumulative loss of mi okay so
so that this second term is just mean
so you can get something like this again
q in the worst case t so in the worst
case you're not getting anything but
hopefully uh
for many uh benign environments q is
much better than t
and you can also get something even
better that depends only on the variance
of the best arm
not just the variance of all the arms
okay this is uh
you can get root cube star k
and
another kind of
measures of easiness is the the kind of
the path length of the losses or the
variation over time okay so look at lt
minus lt minus one
you can look at the the maximum over all
the arms you can get this
you can also just look at the the
variation of only the best arm
okay let's go v star then you can get
something like this
so you pay an extra k here and that
turns out to be unavoidable for adaptive
adversary
which i'm not going to discuss in detail
and the last one i want to mention is
just kind of the sparsity of rewards
okay so i've been using losses and now i
kind of switch to reverse uh by taking
like one minus the one vector minus lt
and then count how many number zero you
have okay and so i'm doing this because
if you think about it sparse losses uh
it's easy right if only a couple few
arms have have losses then this is an
easy instance
while for sparse rewards
it's a hard it's a harder and harder
problem right only a few arms has a
reward and you have to pick those up
so
this positive reward is harder and this
is saying that even for the harder case
you can get root ts so you have no
explicit dependence on the number of
arms but only on the sparsity
okay so that's also possible
and
okay so so
so these are all nice and in fact they
also have imp very nice implications for
for games so if you use this algorithm
to play games in particular these these
the the first and the third time you you
will
you can show that it leads to faster
conversions than using the uh let's say
the mini max optimal algorithm
okay so i'm not going to discount this
but the intuition for example for this
one it's just that
this is measuring your regret with
respect to the variation of the
environment
and
in a game setting your environment is
determined by your determined by your
opponents and your opponents is most
likely doing a learning algorithm as
well and most learning algorithms they
are stable
okay if your opponents are stable then
it means that your environment is also
stable
and that's why you can show that this
path render indeed much better than
linear t or o of t in those cases
and that's why you can use this bound to
get even faster convergence for games
yes
sorry
this is a statement about
all algorithms in this environment or um
just algorithms designed with like
keeping the pathways
in mind for example
uh
wait your question is like whether every
phrase have to use the same algorithm
um is the faster convergence in these
environments for all algorithms or
algorithms that are designed with these
properties in mind
yeah only for these properties that's
what i'm trying to tell you why these
properties are important and one reason
is that if you have this property you
have faster emotions
that's what i'm saying
it makes sense why b star should help
did you say a little bit
about why
okay
yes uh frankly i don't remember that
it's from this paper
right
goes through
oh
i'm just going to show you quickly how
to achieve the first and the third type
of bonds okay again using the ftr
so the first one getting root l star so
you should usually we call it smallest
bounds
and you can get it via this this
algorithm
again there are several different
approaches and i'm taking the one from
this phosphate though okay
so you do ftir but with yet another
neo-regularize which is a lump area okay
it looks like this
i mean in a sense it's also one another
uh limit of service entropy but we don't
need to worry about that it's just
simply
a negative log pi
okay
so just do this and again
apply this general bound and see what's
the trade-off between the penalty and
the stabilization now
okay so the first thing that's tricky is
the the penalty now you cannot simply
bound it by the range because the range
of lobby is actually infinity and when
you put all the weight on one arm then
this actually is infinity
right
so that's one kind of subtle thing about
a barrier but it doesn't mean that you
cannot use it in fact just pick the your
compat your comparator
to be something very close to uh putting
all the weight on i start
but mixed with the uniform let's say one
over t amount of uniform over all the
arms
okay
so you're almost competing with the best
arm just up to one over t
term
okay so so it it's easy to say that so
see that it doesn't affect your regret
because
this is only one over t per round so
over t rounds it only gives you like a
one regret
okay
but it helps a lot in terms of bounding
the penalty because now every pi
p star i has a lower bound of one over t
k
so so that this log one will p i think
cannot
explode
okay
and if you do that you can show that the
the the now this penalty term is just
bounded by k log t
okay so just one subtle thing about log
barrier
okay and then now let's look at the
stability term again
let's just do a second derivative right
first derivative is one opi second
derivatives one over p i squared
so take the inverse you get p square
so there's yet uh
uh
even smaller than uh stylus entropy
okay
and of course in your expectation uh you
get your speedy.lt which is of order 01.
okay and now you see that uh this is a
new tradeoff for log barrier you're
getting a t k long t penalty versus 101
stability
okay
so you see that this is actually even
worse than strand and entropy if you
look at the product
you have block t and stuff lock k it's
not min max optimal
but the nice thing is that it's this
term
let's not bound it by one
let's come back and just just bound it
uh
let's take the optimizator
and then you get something like this
your regret is root k
expected loss of the algorithm
okay
and in fact this actually implies root k
loss of the best arm
okay there are many ways to do it one
way to see it is that the regret is this
term minus l star
right the difference between the loss of
the yoyoism and l star so you can see
this as the quadratic inequality of root
loss of algorithm then just solve for it
and then you get this
okay
but the the
quick message message is just that this
bound imply
the small spawn that we want
yes is there any reason to use entropy
regularizer instead of log barrier for
example
well for example it gives you this kind
of
just one dimension
i mean it depends on uh what do you mean
by dominating but lobby has many not
nice properties that ever mentioned and
this is one of the nice
property of uh from there right so what
is the
like what is the negative thing about
like why would i not always use love
then
uh first of all you get they give you
the long teaser right you get a lot of t
entropies in the world
and
um second i mean
when you when you're doing the spending
with structure for example contextual
band which have similar losses then you
have to use energy
somehow because
for all the other regularizers the
penalty something depends on the number
of force
which a bit polynomially in the number
of points only entropy gets your
logarithmic dependence
but okay just for multi and bandages
again i guess the difference is just log
t versus no routine
the career
okay so that's how you get this kind of
small spout and
finally let me also tell you how to get
this path transparent the boundary
depends on the variation of the losses
okay so you're gonna still use lobaria
as the regularizer in ftrl but you're
going to do a variation of ftr you do
something called optimistic or
predictive ftr
okay the only difference is it's just
this mt term okay
so it's saying that at time t
before i play the game i will make a
prediction mt
on the loss vector for this time okay so
md you should see it as a prediction for
lt
and i should construct it based on all
the information i have at the beginning
of time t
okay i will talk about how to construct
this later after we see the bounce but
now it's just a general predictor for lt
okay let's say you construct you sum
somehow come up with this predictor and
you just
put it into this update rule okay
and so uh it turns out that you can
prove something like this uh with
penalties i'm still the same but the
blizzard term becomes like how accurate
your prediction is which is very natural
right uh this measuring the difference
between lt hat and empty uh with respect
to the local node
okay
so now let's just do the calculation
penalty term is the same nothing changes
it's still just about the log barrier so
it's bounded by k log t
so to really you utilize this stability
term what you what we need to do is use
a kind of a variance reduced estimator
okay something like this
so okay when empty zero obviously it's
just the same as the importance rated
estimator that we had before
and now you you do something like that
you substitute mdi in the numerator here
and then plus mti here
okay so again it's computable and it's
unbiased right when you take expectation
this cancel with pti and minus mti
cancel with plus mti
so it's still unbiased
the the the reason we use it is that not
now if you look at this stabilization
okay which by definition is just this
okay now i haven't used the definition
of mt yet
now now let's plug in mti
you see that it's simply this
okay so the plus mti cancel with minus
mti
and then a
pts square cancel and you just get this
thing times the indicator so i can just
write it in this way
it's the kind of the the error of your
predictor for the arm you selected
the square error
so did you say how you get cleared empty
or no i haven't told you to everything
now is uh
for general empty and and
in the
just a second i will tell you how to
pick empty
okay
so but so far again everything holds as
long as you can construct mt at the
beginning of time t
okay so let me just assume mg is also
between 0 and 1
which is then you can just find by the
absolute value
okay
so
okay so if you look at this if i can
pick mt
uh i so empty to be
lt minus one then this is exactly the
variation
right
but the thing is just that each time i
only see one coordinate so maybe last
round i i am not picking the same arm so
so i don't have that
information okay
and so the natural thing to do is just
to
instead let mti to be the most recently
observed loss for rmi
okay so ideally i want to use the loss
for last round but i don't i might not
have it so let me just use the most
recent
recent round that i select selected
disarm
okay
and
and so if you do this
uh let's just do this simple calculation
the first step is it's just rewriting
i'm still not using the definition of mt
yet right just writing sum of i and then
look at all the id being i okay but now
if you look at this term and by the
differential of md and do a triangle
inequality you just get
the variation
right this is a simple triangle
inequality
okay
so that's that's how you get a variation
out of this depleted term
and again if it means that if the
environment slowly changing you get your
stability is much better than o of t
last step but the optimal either you get
this
any questions
okay so okay at this point we have seen
two nice examples of uh uh oh nice
applications of lobaria so i'm just
gonna mention a bunch of uh
other nice properties of barrier without
going into detail so it turns out to be
again like i said earlier it's
surprisingly powerful for maybe
just for this support it might not be
useful for like i said like contextual
branding and other stuff but it's just
surprisingly powerful for
maybe so
so earlier i said that service entropy
enjoyed the best of both worlds it's
optimal both in the adversarial case and
uh the cast case but turns out that long
barrier also enjoys something like this
so it's even discovered even earlier
than the sarasota should be
okay
and
uh
it's a tool it's also true to stabilize
the algorithm so if you look at the
trade-off the penalty and stability
tradeoff low barrier has the smallest
stability it means that this is the most
stable algorithm in this spectrum
okay so you can use it as a tool to
stabilize algorithm and to get some very
nice properties especially when combined
with other regularizers and again i'm
not going to talk about details but we
have been used there's a sequence of
papers used combining lab barrier with
all kind of different other regularizers
to achieve all kind of different
nice
properties
and finally
there's also a trick that you can do for
a liberia if you increase ada
occasionally in some specific way that
again i'm not going to talk about then
you will obtain a negative regret term
in your request for free okay you will
get everything you have before uh and
then a negative term okay that looks
like this so the negative term depends
on the probability of picking the the
best um
so if at some point in this learning
process you pick the best um with a very
small probability
so that actually means that
even though i start is overly the best
maybe at some point it wasn't the best
and you always was picking something
even better
so that's why it's possible to obtain
something negative so you're doing even
better than i start at some point
okay and this kind of language negative
term is very useful turns out uh you can
use it to do many different things um
but we first realized it in this 2017
paper when we are trying to combine
different banded algorithms
which is a notoriously difficult problem
i guess i will skip this but another
very easy uh to see application is uh
obtaining high probability bound so so
far i have been discussing expected
bound so when you try to derive a
hyperbolism you just you need to do a
concentration okay so for the
concentration around the optimal arm
the variance is exactly something like
this so let's say when you apply it like
freeman you get a variance that looks
like this
and then this negative term will exactly
cancel the variance
and that's how you can get a
high probability bound for for band
that's one way to do it for maybe but as
far as i know it's the only efficient
and optimal way to do it for something
called linear bandits
okay so that's just a slide to convince
you that uh knob barrier turns out to be
very useful for this problem
so uh so there's some open questions
should i
should i stop at 15 or
okay then maybe let me
skip okay so let me talk about only the
second one okay so the first one is just
about log log terms can i get this
without log terms so the one i show you
has log t
so can i remove it
kind of a niche problem
the second one is probably more
interesting so can i get second order
password and spell so by that i mean the
following so all the bounce i have shown
you something like this it's first order
in the sense that there's no square here
so square the second order path inbound
would be something like this
and i'm asking whether this is
obtainable which is unknown okay if the
answer is yes for full information
that's well known
and another reason that you you should
care about this is that again going to
going back to this game application
first order means one over two to three
quarter convergence and second order
means even fast one over t
because that's why
uh we wanna get this it's meaningful to
get this
and i'm saying that even for two arms
and the case let's assume the
environment is super stay stable where
the variation is just 01 we don't have
an answer for this question
okay so i invite many of you
to who are interested to work on this
all right so let me conclude
uh so let me conclude by first telling
you a diff again highlighting the
differences between uh full info in full
information case and the band case
so we have seen the uh this uh of course
a difference in the minimax regret so if
it's full information you get root t
locking
but in bandit when you have only roughly
one okay one over k fraction of the
information you should pay for okay okay
here
and for adaptive regret we discuss all
these bound and so in full information
you can get all these even with second
order passage
okay
so these are the things that we have
discussed today and i will roughly go
over something that
that we didn't discuss but but it's kind
of interesting different differences
between these two cases
so the first one is uh something called
switching cost so sometimes you have
application where you don't want to
frequently switch between different arms
so let's say you're doing dynamic
pricing each arm is a price obviously
you don't want to change your price
every day
okay so one way to do to kind of
formulate this problem is to uh let's
say your goal is to minimize regret plus
the number of switchings
over
over the t rounds okay
so that's what i mean by switching costs
and to it turns out that in fuel
information case you can get it for free
so you can still get the minimax optimal
amount and with only root t switches
so you can you can get the exact same
thing
but to inside that for bandit you really
have to pay for something the the best
thing you can do is indeed i teach 230.
so if you insist on root t regret then
you have to switch for linear time so
the
uh
the algorithm isn't penalized i mean the
opt isn't penalized for switching oh
you're comparing to the best fixed arm
so there's no switches yes i'm still
competing with the best fixed arm but i
penalize myself if i switch
okay
again you cannot get routine regret and
submit your switches the best tradeoff
is rookie request and that's right here
two cents request to a certain box
another
this thing is the interval regret that i
hinted earlier so so standard regret
compete with best time over all time so
now
let's look at interval regret which can
be with the best term on some interval
okay for any interval from s to t let's
look at the regress only for that
interval
a which is useful for a dynamic
environment where you don't have a fixed
uh a fixed arm that's good overall
okay
so and of course you want to do it uh
you want to have a good request
simultaneously for all intervals
okay in full information k you get the
most natural bar root t minus s log k
okay so the length of the interval log k
that's the best you can get
okay for bend it
turns out that provably you cannot get
this
and you can you can get something like
root t k even though the interval is
small you still need to pay for t
instead of the length of the integral
and finally the last thing is very
related to interval regress is something
called switching regret not to be
confused with the switching cost so it's
it's saying that let's say this can be
with a sequence of uh changing arms just
switches at most s times switches at
most s times
so again this is useful like dynamic
environment where you don't have a fixed
good arm but let's say if i let allow it
to switch s times maybe i can find a
good sequence okay
so in this case again for unknown s uh
you can get root as t log k
in the full info case and that's simply
an implication of interval request
because you just sum up the regret on
every interval and the player crosses
one that's why the s is appearing
appearing inside the square root
okay
so for the the band the case is actually
quite intriguing
for adaptive adversary just a recent
paper by uh marinov and zinmat showed
that it's impossible
for our previous surgery we don't know
it is that's also open
and of course by summing up this bound
you can should be requested as root tk
so that's kind of trivially what you can
achieve and this this is ideally what
you want to achieve but we don't know
yet how to do it for our previous
service or whether it's imp it is
possible
all right i'm happy to discuss all these
uh uh after my talk let me just
summarize the technique uh central
tennessee as you can see already
is to design an algorithm for the full
info case first so i discussed uh ftr on
this stock but there are at least two
other general framework uh one is online
new design one is for the leader you can
you can also use this framework for
bandit as well
the second is design loss estimators and
as you probably know now the the real
challenge is that you need to find the
right combination of these two
that so that the variance is well
controlled using the local norm in the
stability term
and this the next is applicable for many
other
problems such as bandit with all sorts
of structures similar to what uh shipper
was
saying this morning
i can also do it for a more general
problem called partial monitoring that
captures things like apple tasting
dynamic pricing etc
and of course you can also do it for
reinforcement learning as well you can
generalize some of these techniques for
learning markov decision processes even
with adversarial losses
and with that i will just stop here
thanks for your attention
you have time for some questions so just
a brief announcement before that so
after this we have a t um but instead of
having it inside what we the staff have
put the tea next to the door and the
suggestion would be you can grab with
the insides and then head outside so
that you would have to wear glasses
but yeah throw it open to questions
i'm curious about you mentioned that
is good for stability meaning having
small
stability or good stability is that true
for
general measures of stability like
stability against
observation error things like that or is
just the term that we call stability
term
you know yes
so so so i mentioned this at best double
small thing
that it also adapts to stochastic losses
so in fact it's also the uh so it's
the castle
it also adapts to its corruption to the
stochastic
the discovery related to this
with error in the observation it can
also adapt to it so in that sense it is
stable even against this paper discuss
those kind of
is that known to be optimal in all cases
like do we know any case where we need
to do something fantastic
not that i'm not aware of yeah
yeah so just this is enough for us
yes yeah
that's the best thing
so there's a robot i mean this paper i
mean otherwise that you should be able
to just e-pumpkin i can tell you more
but this paper is mostly just about
lower
and it's very interesting because we
don't really have a lot of teacher tools
on this kind of literature
yes
you
yes
why is that exactly
okay i mean it's not a real isn't that
trick because like i said you just need
to
translate it to
uh uh losses and and
and i'm just saying that oh wait it's
probably two
minutes nice ago but and saying that
that's for someone with you cannot do
negative losses as the rewards because
that will discourage exploration
for death specific hours
let's see for the system
but did you do that shifting do you have
to do it
before you compute l hat because m hat
will not yes
yes
yeah i mean it seemed like this was
giving esp4 if you just actually think
of one minus
yeah that was kind of what i was
thinking it's all variants that depend
on variance this may be made
this may be a good question for you so
yeah
uh so 3 45 everyone fedoris will tell us
why